and a Housing Development could soon be
coming right to the middle of Red Rock
Canyon but several residents not happy
so this is the area where it would be
built Blue Diamond Hill near gypsum mine
Madison Kimbrough was at today's County
Commission meeting where people
certainly expressed their concerns about
those possible plans Madison joins us
from The Newsroom with more on what was
said and what the next steps are in this
development process yeah it was a
unanimous vote this afternoon to
continue with phase one of the
development for home set to be built on
top of Blue Diamond Hill in the middle
of Red Rock
developer Jim Rhodes with gypsum
resources wants to build 429 homes in
the area that of which residents of Red
Rocks say violates county code and
previous legal agreements the other
concern being that it will congest an
already rocky area putting cyclists in
other people's lives at risk there's
only one road that goes through it it's
the scenic byway Highway 159 there have
been a lot of accidents out there
there's lots of mining trucks that go up
and down and if we add to that mix
construction trucks construction traffic
all the extra commuters
it's just going to be even more
dangerous Heather Fisher belongs to the
save red rock group she along with
several other members showed up pleading
to Commissioners to not let this
development happen but in the end phase
one is now in fruition
and so what's next the developer gypsum
resources has four years to obtain paved
legal right-of-way access from the BLM
that's Bureau of Land Management for a
residential development reporting in The
Newsroom Addison Kimbrough news now